So if the learning goal of this class is
that you would know enough to contribute
to the educational technology community,
what's the learning outcome?
A learning outcome is
something demonstrable.
A learning goal is something you
should know by the end of the course.
A learning outcome is something
you should be able to do.
And here the learning outcome is
a subtle twist on that learning goal.
If the goal is to know
enough to contribute,
the outcome is that you will
have actually contributed.
Now of course the way you contribute
is dependent on your interests or
your passions in this class.
For example, if you're more interested
in designing educational technology,
then your contribution and your learning
outcome will be that you have actually
designed educational technology.
If you're interested more
on the research side,
then by the end of this course your
outcome will be you have done research.
You have actually participated in
researching educational technology and
made a contribution to
the research community.
So depending on your interests, the
nature of your learning outcomes will
differ, but the overall outcome
is the same for everybody.
By the end of this class,
you should be able to, and in fact,
you will have contributed to
the educational technology community.